- [Voiceover] What I want
to do in this video is
make a little bit of what I
talked about in the last video,
a little bit more concrete.
So, let's say that the year is,
for the sake of simplicity,
let's say it's 1996
1996, and the current interest rates,
and I'm just going to
use round numbers here,
they don't have to be exact,
as long as you get the general idea.
Let's say the current interest
rates in the United States
are 8%,
8% interest rates in the United States,
and let's say that in Thailand,
in Thailand, let's say,
Thailand, let's say that
the interest rates are
12%.
So, the last video we talked about
that you have this
interest rate discrepancy,
their exchange rate is being pegged
by the Thai Central Bank,
it's being managed,
this could be a tempting way to make money
for a Thai financial institution.
So, let's say it's 1996,
you're a Thai financial institution,
you borrow a million dollars,
so you borrow, you
borrow 1 million dollars,
and this is the part where
we're going to make it
a little bit more concrete,
and in 1996 the exchange rate,
let's say it's 25 Baht per dollar.
So, then you convert that,
you convert that into,
and you're borrowing one million dollars,
let's say you're borrowing it at 8%,
and then you convert
that to 25 million baht.
So, this gets turned into 25 million
25 million baht,
that you then lend at 12%,
That you just then lend at 12%.
Now, let's just say for
the sake of simplicity,
this is an interest only loan,
and that the principal
is due in two years.
So, we're going to call
this a two year loan.
So, this is a two year loan.
So, let's think about what happens,
how you can make money
as long as the currency
stay stable,
and how this loan will really burn you
if something happens with the currency.
Especially if the Baht were to devalue
relative to the US Dollar.
So, while the two currencies are stable,
every year you're going to make 12%
on the 25 million baht that you lent,
and that is what?
12% of 25 million,
that's going to be what?
Four million a year?
And I'll get the calculator out
just to verify that for you.
So, if I have 25 times
so this gonna be in millions,
so, 25 times 12%, it gets us,
oh sorry, three million,
I was doing my mental map incorrectly.
So, that gives you three
million baht a year,
you're going to make in interest.
So, this is going to be three million,
so, you're going to
get three million baht,
it's going to come from
whoever borrowed that money,
three million baht,
and then to pay the interest that you owe
on that dollar loan,
you can then convert that into,
you're going to get 25,
you're going to have 25 baht per dollar,
so let's convert that into dollars,
so three million baht,
if you divide it by 25,
is going to be,
so this is in millions,
so this is $120,000.
So you convert this into $120,000,
so it becomes $120,000,
and how much interest do you have to pay?
Well, you have to pay 8% on the million,
which is $80,000.
So, you subtract out
the 80,000 in interest,
minus 80k interest,
and you're left with $40,000 per year.
$40,000 per year profit.
40 per year,
and this is just off of a million dollars,
you can imagine if you did
this with a billion dollars,
or any amount of money,
you're just getting this
what seems like an
almost risk free profit.
The reason why I say it's
almost is that this is all
contingent upon this
exchange rate staying stable.
Now let's see how you get
burned when you have this
devaluation of the baht.
And the first place it'll
just become much harder
for you to do this interest.
So, now all of a sudden the currency's,
the baht devalues and you go to,
let's say you go to,
I'll just pick an arbitrary
point right over here,
you get to a situation where
you're at 45 baht per dollar.
So, let me write this,
so you have devaluation,
devaluation,
and now you have 45,
45 baht per US dollar.
Up here it was 25 baht per US dollar.
So, let's say this is happening,
this is 1997 that we're talking about.
Now, how'd the dynamics play out?
Well, now your three
million baht in interest,
'cause remember you lent this in baht,
your three million baht,
let me write this down,
are going to be how many dollars?
Let's get our calculator out,
so now you're going to have three million,
and you're going to
have 45 baht per dollar,
so divided by 45, you get
this is going to be about $67,000.
So, this right over here is going to be
equivalent to at this new exchange rate
$67,000.
But your interest that
you owe on the dollar loan
is $80,000.
$80,000 in interest,
and so you actually have
this $13,000 deficit
that you're going to have to pay
out of your pocket.
So, now your little attempted arbitrage
is working against you.
But that's not the horrible part,
you might be able to still
dig up some money to pay this off.
But the horrible part is
what happens when you have to
pay off the principal,
this was a two year loan.
So, in 1998 you're going
to have to pay back
the million dollars.
Well, if everything worked out,
if the exchange rate had stayed stable,
the people you lent the money to
would give you 25 million baht,
you would be able to convert
that into a million dollars
and pay off the loan.
But now that there's
been this devaluation,
in 1998,
in 1998, so 1998,
the people you lent the money to,
assuming you lent it responsibly,
and even that's in question,
because the whole country was entering in
something of a bubble,
but you're going to get 25 million,
you're going to get 25 million Thai Baht,
but you're not going to
be able to convert it
into a million dollars anymore.
We're going to have to
divide this number by 45.
So you divide 25,
divided by 45,
you're going to be able
to convert it to about
$556,000.
So, $556,000, which is too bad
because you owe a million dollars.
You're going to be nearly $450,000 short,
you're going to take a
huge hit on this trade
that you were doing just
to make $40,000 here,
because the baht devalued.
And you can imagine,
as people saw this coming,
so for whatever reason
people started to get afraid,
they started to convert out of the baht,
stop investing in Thailand as much,
they started to realize that
some of those investments
made in those earlier years
might have been going into
kind of a speculative bubble.
But then when this becomes apparent
that there might actually be
a banking crisis going on,
because all of these
banks were doing this,
all of these actually formal banks
or even informal financial institutions
were doing this trade,
and it could bring down the
entire Thai financial system,
it became even a more
self-fulfilling prophesy.
Because now investors
were even more afraid
to invest in Thailand,
even more people were to pull out,
and that would deplete the
Thai Central Bank's reserves
even more,
and then on top of that,
even Thai citizens would become
afraid of the banking sector,
they would go to their banks,
they want their demand deposits back,
and we all know how a
fractional reserve system works,
that by itself is a bank run,
and so the banks wouldn't even
have the reserves to pay it.
So, even before the
banks take the hit here,
when people see it coming,
it could bring down the entire system.